[Music]
so sorry the uh
the lighting in here is not great this
is i'm actually in our screening room at
the studio
and i think they just have it kind of
dark so that you know you can watch you
know
we shoot scenes in the woods at night
with zombies so it's like they need it
as dark as possible they just turn off
the lights and have to worry about it
but it's like doing a zoom uh thing is
not good i mean eleanor is lit so
perfectly and so are you steve for that
matter josh thank you
huh you look better than usual don't
worry about it i showered through it
[Music]
you look great josh everyone i am joined
by josh mcdermott aka eugene and el
ormat surah aka yumiko i am so excited
to be with the two of you together uh
and the walking dead final season is
premiering this sunday and it's already
out on amc plus so how you guys doing
today i mean you're both in totally
different environments but you both seem
like you're doing
great yeah
i'm doing awesome and you just said it's
it's premiering this sunday and i can't
believe that i mean it's like it's
always been this date off into the
future
i mean when did we start shooting like
in january eleanor it was just like yeah
and well february february yeah it was
so far after the future and all of a
sudden you're saying it's airing this
sunday and i'm like what the crap
yeah it's it's here and it's it's crazy
and there's already so much buzz around
it and speaking of that buzz eleanor you
had shared on your instagram a picture
of this billboard with you right in the
center of it which is amazing and they
put josh right in the right corner how
did that make you feel well i actually
asked them to do that because if anybody
knows us who works in the show like
obviously josh and i
are friends on the show but i actually
asked for him to be not next to me
because i just find it distracting i i
always try and have at least one
person's distance that includes um
poster press like
that's why we could have been together
in the same room right now but that's
why i made him go to the studio because
i don't want him
that's how we do it yeah and and i
actually haven't seen that yet and it's
because
i said look if i'm not in the middle or
standing next to elmore then i don't
even want to see it
so that's why i haven't even seen it yet
well you know what josh you make up for
it because
you are just incredible in these first
two episodes of the new season with no
spoilers you have an incredibly
emotional monologue that we're gonna see
it's probably my favorite scene of
eugene yet if you told josh who was
doing last comic standing in the past
that you were gonna be capable of doing
a scene like this would you have
believed him
um i would have i would have believed it
because i always knew that i could do uh
drama but i just didn't i didn't think
that i ever would if that makes sense
you know the capability i felt like was
there and so
um you know i just love how eugene's
changed so much and you know thank you
for saying that you feel like that's
your favorite eugene scene i mean that's
uh
it's definitely up there with one of my
favorites as well it's
it's an interesting uh first couple of
episodes you know it's it's you know
we're meeting the the
the first
the outer bands of the commonwealth and
um
it's it's exciting to see everybody's
reaction to that
um you know everybody's on this journey
together but they're all doing it for
their own individual reasons they're all
looking for something and hoping they
find it at the commonwealth and so it's
fun to see the other characters
you know really um
you know see how that's messed with with
them right to see if it's like if
they're going to achieve their goal and
their wants and desires
and um yeah that's that's really kind of
what we start to unpack in those first
couple of episodes
yeah totally and it really takes you and
eleanor's character and like puts them
in these big scenes and big moments
because you guys are this group you're
in now and your characters have so much
screen time together but you have these
moments of emotional heavy lifting and
eleanor was going to say is that that
comes with you two are was really my
favorite scenes of eleanor and there's
just these great monologues you do we
see her lawyer side start to come out
did you feel a different type of nerves
on set for this season doing that much
heavy lifting or do you kind of embrace
that challenge
oh yeah a bit of both actually it's a
really good question i mean
i i really feel like similar to josh
it's sort of
i know that i can do that and i really
come from a theater background and so
like i'm kind of used to like long
shakespearean speeches you know that's
sort of what i do but i've never done
that on the show we've there's never
been a need or a cause to do that in in
yumiko's story in the show so
even though i've always had that kind of
in my wheelhouse it's so awesome to have
an opportunity to actually do it and
it's make
perfect sense um because we learn that
unico has this completely
different like
strong set of skills that she's never
had to use before because you know she's
just been surviving literally like with
you know hands
out in the woods looking for food now
we're talking about the strength of her
intellect and her brain and her her wit
and like that's like she hasn't had to
to use that in that way before but was i
nervous yeah like that was a big speech
and i remember thinking
don't
it up because it's this is an
opportunity for the beginning of
yumiko's story so it's an important step
and i was also yeah real quick steve
i think we shot our each of our scenes
on back-to-back days and i was checking
in with eleanor she shot hers first i
was like because we look we hadn't been
working
on this show for you know 18 months
or what have you and so
this was like one of the first things we
did when we got back to work and it was
you know we're both trying to have to
blow the rust off a little bit and just
like kind of you know not we're not
fully stretched yet and i remember
checking in being like hey how was it
she's like oh we're going to be fine
it's going to be great
you know she had just finished it she's
like we're good it's going to be great
no that that's amazing and it's so funny
too because josh your character of
eugene like we always know he has some
moments he's so incredibly anxious and
he's high strung and you you kill it in
all these moments and you have this
range as an actor that just blows me
away but when i'm talking to you now
you're that just shows you the skill is
that like you're this is chill dude that
i can i i don't i can't even believe
your eugene is what i'm saying that's a
compliment so is it easy though for you
to snap out of that do you feel like
some of you gene is seeping into josh in
real life like being high strung and
stuff
um
well that's an interesting question yeah
i mean look i'm i
you say i'm a just chill guy i don't
feel it i'll tell you that i mean i may
be kind of stoic at times but like
inside i'm just a hurricane um
yeah no i there's definitely some bleed
over with eugene and and and vice versa
you know i think um i think every actor
experiences that where where when you've
played a character for so long
but you know yeah for sure like eugene
has definitely had these moments where
he's had to he's had to be
he's been stretched emotionally
and um anxiety is is a big part of his
life at this point and i just think that
you know as we start to see him enter
into the commonwealth now
uh we're going to see more and more
of that i don't necessarily think it's
something that goes away especially this
far into the apocalypse
for sure yeah and
speaking of that too with something that
doesn't go away and how long we've known
eugene as a character josh is this
super emotional for you being that
you've been on the show for so long like
something a lot of people don't get
experienced as being
on set during a final season and being
on a show that long what was that kind
of feeling for you
yeah i mean it's real it's bittersweet i
mean we we've been at it for a long time
um
and even today as i was driving into the
studio i you know
i it's not lost on me that you know the
days are numbered
the the amount of times i'm going to be
driving in and even sitting in like this
this is a wall of death right here we
have it here and eleanor knows this but
we got it here we have these are all the
people that have died on our show and so
we're constantly reminded of the legacy
here and so it's uh it is emotional
coming in and just seeing that you know
yeah this is we're very lucky and
fortunate to number one make it to
season 11 on any television show when so
many shows get canceled after the first
or second seasons but also the fact that
you know so many people have come and
gone before us and we're still standing
and that's um
you know that's not lost on us and so
it's it's it's certainly uh
it's emotional it's bittersweet you know
i think it's time
uh to
for the show to
to branch out and to do other things and
to move on i guess
um
but also i don't want to let go of it
yet
sure no and it's i feel like i'm getting
like these different vibes because
you're in the room with the wall of
death there i hope it's not
foreshadowing anything for eugene and
then you got eleanor in this bright room
and eleanor you would mention it's like
the start of yumika yumiko's character
so it's like
i'm wondering is there a chance for a
spin-off for her would you be open
opportunity to be jumping even on
another walking dead show oh gosh i
don't know i mean like it's kind of
weird to think about you know what's
funny this is the time for this
the time is already going so fast as
josh said like i can't believe we're
premiering the first episode like this
weekend it's totally mad at the same
time we're sort of at the halfway point
so the end for me is still a long way to
go i can't believe what you see in the
trailer
is only a third of what we've done there
is so much that's going to happen in
this season it's an extended season it's
just
like
you won't believe the amount of stories
like news stories that we're still
managing to cram in let alone tying up
old ends so to talk about like
spin-offs and like things in the future
seems so abstract to me and i'm just
going to be trying to avoid the question
it's just i can't
i just i just can't like i can't put my
head there right yet i'm just like i
mean sure yeah cool i'd love to see
yubico go on and have all these
different lives of course i would but
but the reality of what that really
looks like i don't know i don't know i'm
so i'm still in this world so much right
now it feels too weird i would love to
see a spin-off with you eleanor just
yumiko is it's like law and order zombie
and she's just
some zombie on the stand and she's like
did you or did you not eat his guts and
he's like
and you're like
i love it that's that's just a great
idea right there um i'm so excited for
people to see you guys together
in this new final season i'm honored to
be joining you i feel like i'm part of
the crew right now at the commonwealth
so this is really a dream for me um
thank you guys for joining me everybody
watch the walking dead season 11 final
season premieres this sunday it's
already out the premiere on amc plus and
i hope to talk to you guys again in the
future one day
thank you so much